le chef du npd est avec nous bonsoir
jazz meeting
bonsoir commençons par la loi 21 alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire oui ou
non il est possible qu'un jour vous
contestez cette loi j'étais tellement
clair sur cette position
oui je ne veux je ne veux pas un devenir
il vient poursuites si tu aimes en
partant je suis un avocat
donc je ne veux pas intervenir ce que je
veux faire c'est de montrer que les
politiques des divisions ça fait mal à
la société
je pense qu'il faut toujours trouver des
façons de rassembler les gens moi je
suis quelqu'un qui porte ici une
religion mais je suis pour la droite
d'avortement pour les droits des femmes
si pour les droits des communautés
agitée vécue pour le mariage même sexe
je suis pour la lutte contre la crise
climatique mais quelques comme un dieu
scheer elle est contre tout ça donc
peut-être si on va vraiment avoir la
séparation entre l'église et l'état
il faut renforcer les droits des femmes
des communautés agitée vécue
il faut renforcer les trois que tu t'es
québec toute la nation de québec partage
mais peut-être comme vous répondez par
oui ou par non donc c'est peut-être ça
qui est pas très clair mais hier quand
vous avez dit quand ça se retrouve en
cour suprême
juridiquement le premier ministre
gouvernement fédéral doivent regarder ce
qui se passe qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire par là est-ce que vous ouvriez par
la pop
non j'ai répété une fille c'est
seulement un fait mais je veux être
clair j'étais toujours clair je ne veux
pas intervenir
ce que je veux faire et donc gagner les
coeurs déjà en cour suprême
si ça sera en cour suprême comme
historiquement le gouvernement fédéral a
toujours fait quand ça touche la
constitution vous allez regarder dans
placo c'est ça que vous l'ayez c'est
selon un fait tu les aiglons
on le sait le devoir de faire ça mais ce
que j'ai dit est ce que je veux quand
encore répéter parce que c'était ma
position tout le temps je ne veux pas
intervenir
ce que je veux faire clairement c'est de
gagner le coeur des gens parce que je
peux je pense des jeunes qui veulent
être veut être devenir enseignant ou
enseignante et ce moment à cause d'une
loi ne peux pas je pense des jeunes qui
veut devenir policier ou avocats qui ont
dans leur car le
désir d'aider la société est maintenant
il ne peut pas et ça me rend triste
parce que je sais toujours
souvent les gens font face les barrières
à cause de leur identité et ça me rend
triste parce que je veux bâtir société
où tout le monde est célébrée pour leur
identité mais justement pourquoi comment
comment vous expliquez que vous n'allez
pas au bout de vos convictions et vous
ne vous n'allez pas faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour défendre justement les
minorités qui ont l'air de vous tenir
beaucoup à coeur ce que je fais tout le
temps
chaque fois quand je suis au québec tous
les journalistes me posent la même
question se maintient c'est toujours le
cas et ça me donne toujours la situe
même et ça ça me donne toujours
l'occasion de dire moi ce que je veux
faire comme quelqu'un qui porte un
turban et imberbes
je veux défendre contre la crise
climatique je veux bâtir une société où
on lutte contre les inégalités socio je
veux défendre les droits des femmes
je veux défendre les droits des
communautés agit d b q donc peut-être je
peux gagner le coeur des gens en
montrant qu'on peut travailler ensemble
il y a des grandes en jeu les ondes yeux
primordial comme la crise climatique
ici à morial on a eu cinq cent mille
jeunes dans les coups qui demande au
gouvernement de prendre des actions
monsieur trudeau elle a acheté un
pipeline mais je veux montrer qu'il y en
option les néo démocrates
on se bat pour vous on se bat pour les
gens on veut ça si on veut s'assurer les
jeunes qui en maintenant dans nos yeux
désespoir je veux dire que l'on va
lutter contre la crise climatique gens
m'ont vu gagner aujourd'hui à vous
parler de cette grande marche qui a un
qui a réuni 500 mille personnes mais
aujourd'hui à des jeunes qui ont décidé
d'utiliser la désobéissance civile ils
ont bloqué un pont ici à montréal a
bloqué la circulation pendant plusieurs
heures
qu'est ce que vous pensez de c est ce qu
on est rendu là pour faire bouger les
choses justement au sujet de l'urgence
climatique est ce qu'on l'ait rendu là
je pense que les jeunes sont frustes et
parce qu'ils ont vu un gouvernement
libéraux qui donne des belles paroles
mais pas des actions concrètes
donc ils sont fâchés et ce moment et
demandent pourquoi le gouvernement ne
prend pas des actions concrètes et
c'était que cela désobéissance civile je
pense qu'il s'éteint c'est un acte que
les gens utilisent quand ils sont fâchés
il ya une histoire de l'utilisation de
ces actes ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on n'est pas dans une situation où il
faut choisir entre des libéraux qui dans
des belles paroles mais pas des actions
ou les conservateurs qui ne comprend pas
la crise climatique
je veux présenter une option avec les
néo-démocrates avec moi comme chef où je
vais les gens disent que les libéraux
proposent au sujet des changements
climatiques
donc on fait une un engagement que
monsieur trudeau a fait qu'il a brisé
c'était de haine dit tout de suite les
subventions pétrolière d'où avec
l'argent public
j'ai engagé de le faire tout de suite on
peut la faire et si on a une annuler les
subventions pétroliers on peut
réinvestir la magie dans l'énergie
propre
on peut rien réinvestir l'énergie
l'argent dans l'énergie renouvelable
donc on peut faire face à cette crise
climatique si on prend des choix mais
pour monsieur trudeau la bande un grand
problème c'est il milite toujours pour
les plus riches les grandes compagnies
pétroliers les lobbyistes et l'écran
qu'on finit par ateliers ont eu des
rencontres avec le gouvernement trudeau
plus de cent mille cinq cents fois donc
après tout ça ils ont prise et la
promesse d'annuler les subventions ils
ont acheté une pipe line
en fait ce que vous feriez justement
avec le pipeline trans matin donc si
vous donnez premier oui bien sûr donc ce
que j'ai dit je veux annulé
l' augmentation de construire une
nouveau pipeline
je suis contre ça je pense qu'il faut
défendre l'environnement
il faut annuler le contrat d'expansion
de exactement tout à vue et savait que
tous les observateurs disent que jusqu'à
votre petit faux pas peut-être d'hier
soir sur la loi 21 mai que vous faites
quand même une bonne campagne que
certains ont dit que vous aviez gagné
même les débats en français en anglais
mais les intentions de vote restent les
mêmes
est-ce que c'est frustrant pour vous moi
je prends pas les choses pour acquis je
travaille tous les temps je me bats pour
les gens tous les temps est ce que je
vais faire je vais travailler très fort
jusqu'à fin pour montrer qu'il y ait en
option moi je ne travaille pas pour les
plus riches je ne travaille pas plus con
compagnie pétroliers
je travaille tous les gens pour monsieur
madame tout le monde donc je vais
montrer ça je garde l'espoir parce que
je sais que les gens méritent plus les
conservateurs et les libéraux il se bat
entre il se débat qui est le mauvais je
veux dire ce n'est pas le bon débat il
faut débattre pour pour monter c'est
quoi la meilleure option pour le canada
c'est quoi la meilleure option pour les
gens et j'ai un engagement un plate
forme d engagement on peut faire ça dans
votre campagne au québec d'une publicité
vous parlez beaucoup du turban turban
pas turban donc c'est quelque chose que
vous savez qui préoccupe les gens
est-ce que vous avez surestimé d'une
certaine façon la capacité des canadiens
à accepter qu'ils vous être avec ce que
vous êtes
je pense que c'est toujours un défi pour
beaucoup de monde de faire face des
barrières à cause de leur identité
j'ai parlé avec mes collègues des femmes
qui font face derrière tous les temps
dans leur cas ryad avancé à cause de
l'argent
non c'est toujours le cas qu'il y à des
barrières à cause d' identité
je veux montrer en 2019 qu' on peut
voter pour quelqu'un qui partage les
mêmes valeurs
ce n'est pas une question d'apparence
est en question des valeurs et moi je
suis pas un francophone mais je suis un
francophile
j'adore la langue française je comprends
qu'il y a une identité unique au québec
je veux le défendre
aussi je vais lutter contre la crise
climatique et ce que je propose je veux
continuer la rêve de jack layton de
travail ensemble avec les progressistes
du québec
l'épreuve de progressis du canada est
ensemble on peut bâtir un meilleur
avenir et les gens qui disent qu'au
québec on n'entend plus le message est
une bd
pourquoi vous pensez je pense que on est
moins des reçus ce parce que les plus
riches et donnent leur argent aux grands
des partis libéraux conservateurs mais
on est fiers de le fait que nous sommes
un parti des travailleurs et
travailleuses et c'est plus difficile
oui mais j'ai pris cet engagement pas
parce que c'était facile je l'a pris
parce que je suis prêt de me battre pour
les gens je suis prêt de défendre les
droits des gens qui à ce moment pense
qu'il n'ya pas il n'y a aucune personne
qui s'occupe de leurs intérêts et moi je
suis ici pour dire qu'on peut investir
dans les soins de santé avec un soin
dentaire qui peut donner des avantages
pour les gens qui n'ont pas les moyens
je peux aider du monde avec nos
engagements
je suis fier de ce qu'on a proposé si
c'est un gouvernement minoritaire c'est
possible vous avez déjà dit que vous ne
vouliez pas travailler avec un
gouvernement conservateur est ce que ça
veut dire que si vous avez la balance du
pouvoir vous faites tomber le
gouvernement conservateur qui sera élu
ce que j'ai dit à cause de la manque de
respect pour la crise climatique avec
les conservateurs avec ce que monsieur
chiffre à 10 contre les droits des
femmes contre les doigts d qui mutile
j'ai vécu que je ne peux pas travailler
avec monsieur chiffres mais si je peux
renverser la question peut si je suis
premier ministre dans un gouvernement
minoritaire
philippe rey je suis prêt de travailler
avec n'importe quelle personne qui
veulent mettre en oeuvre nos valeurs
pour travailler contre la crise
climatique soif les conservateurs mais
si si c'est un gouvernement minoritaire
libéral si c'est encore une hypothèse
mais c'est fort possible
quel serait votre priorité alors
qu'est-ce que comment vous utiliseriez
cette balance du pouvoir sur quoi
j'avais une priorité un mot encore je
veux dire parce que je veux devenir
premier ministre est pour le pays mais
encore je perds publication dans un
situation minoritaire
ce que je veux dire trois priorités
l'environnement
la réforme électorale avec la la torah
forme professionnelle
oui c'est encore possible et finalement
la lutte contre la crise climatique et
soins de santé donc ce sont les
engagements alors je suis souhaiter une
bonne fin de campagne il reste deux
semaines encore de suivre merci beaucoup
je vous en plus